Inside my editMenuItem function,
I see that in my render_template,
I'm passing in three variables that my
editmenuitem.html file is
going to have access to.
The restaurant_id, the menu_id, and
i, which is going to represent
the item we want to edit.
So to edit a new menu item,
I'm going to create a form, just like
I did when I created a new menu item.
Inside the form I'm going to
call my edit menu item function
with the appropriate parameters.
Here I'll prompt for the name of the new
menu item and create an input field.
Using the placeholder attribute of HTML
I can have that field already filled out
with the name of the item
I'm going to edit.
I'll then add a button called Edit.
And here I create another link to
cancel just in case I realize I
actually don't want to
edit my menu item.
When I save and run, I see that I can
now change the name of my menu items.
The solution code for this video is
available in the instructor notes